today on the matt walsh show the senate
held a hearing with the facebook
whistleblower so-called yesterday
setting the stage for what will be the
most far-reaching censorship campaign in
american history also an espn anchor is
pulled off the air after criticizing
vaccine mandates and dave chappelle has
a new comedy special out the media
insists that it is incendiary and
bigoted so you know it must be good and
finally ray spader ibram x kendi
preaches his version of the gospel
message and it is as heretical as you
might expect all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you've been listening to this show
for a while you've no doubt heard me
talk about my helix mattress my helix
mattress which is uh
a cure for insomnia i have not had a
sleepless night since i started using it
well here's the good news helix has
launched a new company called all form
and they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped right to your
door so what makes it all form sofa
really cool well for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize the sofa
using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric and it's
spill stain and scratch resistant the
you could pick the sofa color color of
the legs everything every aspect of it
is customizable they've also got arm
chairs and love seats all the way up to
an eight-seat sectional so there's
something for everyone all form sofas
are also delivered directly to your home
with fast free shipping in the past if
you wanted to order a sofa you know it
could take weeks or even months to
arrive and you would need someone to
come and assemble it in your home but
all form takes just three to seven days
to arrive in the mail and you can
assemble yourself in just a few minutes
it's that easy to do so you want to take
advantage of this right now and get
yourself an all form sofa they look
great they're extremely comfortable and
all form is offering 20 off all orders
to our listeners right now at all form
dot com slash walsh that's all form dot
com slash walsh one thing we heard over
and over again after the january 6th
riots is that the u.s capitol is a
sacred place where the solemn duty of
governing
is performed january 6 was a desecration
of this holy ground that's why the
capital riot was so much worse than all
of the blm riots put together um and and
so much worse than all of the tragedies
of american history put together and you
know because when it comes to the blm
riots blm merely destroyed and
incinerated small businesses and homes
where people and where poor and middle
class people live and maybe a police
station or two or thrown in there
that pales in comparison to breaking a
few windows and overturning some desks
inside the capitol building because the
capitol building is a hallowed temple it
should be revered and venerated
now i personally would have a problem
with this attitude no matter who was in
congress there is nothing sacred about
government there's nothing even all that
special about it frankly there's
certainly nothing venerable or saintly
about the people who work in government
they're supposed to be public servants
doing a job that we elect them to do
that's all
but all this talk about the blessed
sanctified ground of the capital becomes
even more absurd when you consider that
the many ways in which
the people who work in the capital
happily make a mockery of it every
single day
if it were possible to desecrate it
then nobody could possibly desecrate it
more than our elected representatives
themselves they've turned congress into
nothing more than a stage upon which
they can perform their elaborate puppet
shows
case in point yesterday speaking of
puppets the so-called facebook
whistleblower francis haugen was brought
before a senate committee to testify now
as i've already revealed on this show
over the last couple of days halgan is a
far left activist with a history of
donating to far-left politicians like
alexandria casey cortez she's also being
represented by a democrat pr firm and
she has an obvious agenda to push
greater censorship of conservative
content on social media she's also not a
whistleblower she has revealed nothing
new nothing of value about facebook she
hasn't blown the whistle on anything
all of this is nothing but a pageant a
theater performance with the goal of
justifying a far-reaching crackdown on
content that criticizes the democrat
regime
the totally farcical nature of this
whole whistleblower routine became
immediately obvious at the beginning of
haugen's opening statement let's listen
to that yesterday we saw facebook get
taken off the internet
i don't know why i went down
but i know that for more than five hours
facebook wasn't used to deepen divides
destabilize democracies and make young
girls and women feel bad about their
bodies
i mean make women feel bad about their
bodies and we needed congressional
testimony about that
we're supposed to believe
that the self-esteem problems of
internet addicted women justifies at
least partially a nationally televised
senate hearing now listen ladies i'm
sorry if you feel bad about yourselves
when you use instagram i think probably
the best solution would be to stop using
instagram if that's the case
if you're scrolling through instagram
and saying oh this this makes me feel so
bad about myself
six hours later you're still scrolling
maybe connect the dots here put the
phone down
as for your daughters having their
self-image destroyed by social media
i've already argued stridently many
times that the only solution there is to
refrain from buying your child a
smartphone in the first place
so when you've got you know i'm just
imagining this this image of a grown
woman scrolling instagram
and feeling so bad about themselves
sitting next to their daughters also
scrolling instagram
and worrying oh is this making her feel
bad about herself too
put your phones down
take her phone away from her
and besides if we're worried about
websites that cause psychological damage
to people especially kids then why
aren't we hearing senate testimony about
the porn sites that expose millions of
elementary schoolers to hardcore smut
every single day
okay there are sites where where
middle schoolers can be exposed to rape
porn
and there is nothing standing in the way
there's no kind of
filter system
put in place to stop that from happening
why are we talking about that
well because all of this is again a
farce
and the body image nonsense is only a
smoke screen it's a cover
the real agenda is political which
became all the more clear during
questioning especially with uh senator
amy klobuchar let's listen to that
we've seen the same kind of content in
the political
world you brought up other countries and
what's been happening there on 60
minutes you said that facebook
implemented safeguards to reduce
misinformation ahead of the 2020
election but turned off those safeguards
right after the election
and you know that the insurrection
occurred january 6 do you think that
facebook turned off the safeguards
because they were costing the company
money because it was reducing profit
facebook has been emphasizing a false
choice they've said
the safeguards that were in place before
the election
implicated free speech
the choices that were happening on the
platform were really about how reactive
and twitchy was the platform right like
how viral was the platform and facebook
changed those safety defaults in the
run-up to the election because they knew
they were dangerous
and because they wanted that growth back
they wanted the acceleration of the
platform back after the election they
they returned to their original defaults
yes we need safeguards to protect our
democracy by protect our democracy they
mean protect the vice grip hold that the
left has
on our democracy our system
they mean protect the regime
well we've see what we've seen just this
week alone between this uh facebook
whistleblower burlesque and the fbi
going after parents who criticize school
board members what we've seen here is a
full court press panic by the ruling
class to shut down not only criticism
but all avenues for criticism
and they feel morally justified in doing
so because it's what's best for us
we mere mortals are too stupid and
incompetent to arrive at our own
conclusions or form our own opinions
for our own sake they must ensure that
we adopt the conclusions and opinions
that
they assign to us and that's why how
again is being hailed as a courageous
hero by the media in fact cnn
and an interesting choice brought monica
lewinsky on camera to sing halgen's
praises and also to promote her new hbo
documentary let's listen to that i think
that that sort of more importantly what
we've seen kind of from yesterday and i
think it it's worth mentioning that
francis haugen
and testifying how brave she was because
in part what our doc is looking at is
this online behavior that happens and
women and people from marginalized
communities are torn apart way more
online so to come forward as a
whistleblower in that sense is um is
very brave
and i think that what she was also
talking about and and um really
showcasing too with the algorithm and
the um the focus on the outrage you know
where the doc comes into all of this too
is that if you think about the stonings
that happened way back when
the stone that you're picking up and
throwing in the kind of firestorm of
outrage is usually and often is public
humiliation and shame
well incredibly brave yes i mean to come
out in public
and say exactly what those in power want
to hear
and to withstand their universal
applause and acclaim and to ensure that
you'll get a million dollar book deal
and end up on the speaking circuit
making six figures per speech probably
end up with a movie and a mini series
all of that is quite brave
of course the word brave here can be
translated roughly as useful
any complimentary word from the media
always really means useful because they
only approve of actions that are useful
to their agenda so if they're
complimenting you whatever they're
saying what they really mean is useful
as far as that goes
this is all indeed quite useful to them
because they've set the stage now for a
censorship campaign unlike anything
we've ever seen in this country
they can't compete with the other side
intellectually they can't win in a
contest of ideas
so their plan now is to cancel the
contest
and proclaim themselves the winners by
not allowing anybody else
into the arena to begin with
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
you know fall is uh finally here and
what do you want to be doing in the fall
you want to be out you want to be going
for a hike you want to be
skipping through
fields of flowers i guess the flowers
are all dead now but
forget about that let's just talk about
rock auto rock otter.com look it's so
much easier than going into a store and
someone demanding quick answers to the
things that you need or walking around
looking for a specific part you don't
find it they got to order it online
why do that where you can just go to
rockauto.com it's always
offering the lowest prices possible and
always they're giving you the best
selection as well they're a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are reliably low and
they're always the same no matter who
you are the rockauto.com catalog
is unique very easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your car or truck and you can choose the
brands the specifications the prices
that you prefer put all that in
and you just hit go and it pops up
exactly what you're looking for every
time amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need at rockauto.com so go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and wright
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that we sent you well
it's good to be back uh in studio
finally um it is it i i so much prefer
being in a studio than doing these shows
like in a hotel room
it can be it's hard to get into show
mode when you're just sitting in a in a
random hotel room i don't know how but
you know i do the show for my house for
so long and from a car
i don't know how i did that now
probably where the show sucked so much
back then and maybe even still now
but anyway i i have moved back to um to
tennessee so i guess that's that's the
headline here i mean
i after long conversations with uh with
my wife we did finally make the decision
um
and and after being in virginia uh
for for so long i mean for
for dozens and dozens of hours we lived
in virginia
days even
um but finally we made the decision to
relocate and come here to tennessee and
i i think it's the right right decision
for our family my wife had you know
arguments that she made like for example
i don't want to live in some woman's
basement in loudoun county
that was an interesting argument
um and so we decided to move back here
but but virginia you know will even if i
don't have a home in virginia virginia
will have a home in my heart
forever and always
and coming back home
uh to to uh to tennessee when you know
when i got home that i did run into it
to an interesting problem
that i wasn't quite expecting
uh because i got back to the house you
know i've been gone for like almost a
week and a half
and we got this damn dog which i've told
you about and we got the dog
like a day and a half or two days before
i left
so we got the dog i was i was home for
two days and then i left for eight or
nine days and i came home
and i guess the dog
for forgot about me forgot about my
existence
and saw me as kind of an intruder in my
own house
so the dog had had bonded to
my my family to the kids and my wife but
that now i'm an intruder so i get home
and he's like he wouldn't let me go near
my own kids without growling at me i
picked up my daughter and he starts
growling because he thinks that i'm you
know a threat or something
and it's it it really is pretty
outrageous and my my older daughter
comes up to me at some point
and says oh well daddy you have to you
have to you know you have to make the
dog like you why don't you give him some
treats
you know you have to you have to make
him like you
and i said i have to make i'm sorry what
this this mangy mutt is in my house and
i have to win his affections
that's not the way this works
okay
you you have to earn my respect not the
other way around
i go for eight days on a plate i'm
totally replaced by a dog
that's what happens
all right let's
uh let's start with this sage steels an
espn anchor she's the latest to end up
in front of the cancellation firing
squad this is from fox news it says
espn's sportscenter host sage steele
is being pulled off the air following a
remark she made knocking her employer's
vaccine mandate
as well as comments made about former
president obama i think we have we have
the vaccine comments here uh let's let's
play those first this is on a podcast
and this is what she said about vaccine
mandates
i i think to man i respect everyone's
decision i really do but to mandate it
is um
sick
and it's scary to me in many ways um but
i
have a job
a job that i love and frankly a job that
i that i need but again i love it i just
um i'm not surprised it got to this
point especially with disney i mean a
global company yes
so that's what she said now the
headlines are telling you that sage
steel is uh came out as an anti-vaxxer
she came out against vaccines
none of that happened obviously
this is the sleight of hand trick that
that of course we've seen from the left
on this issue just like on every issue
there's always some kind of trick and uh
and that's what it is on this if you're
against vaccine mandates that means that
you're that you're against vaccines in
general
and then about barack obama she says um
talking about
filling out the u.s census form and she
expressed wanting to include multiple
races instead of just one she says if
they make you choose a race um
what are you going to put and i go both
and she's like well you can't
talk about filling out a census form
she goes barack obama chose black and
he's biracial and i'm like
congratulations to the president that's
his thing i think that's fascinating
considering his black dad was nowhere to
be found and his white mom and grandma
raised him but hey you do you i'm gonna
do me
oh okay all right once
right that's deeply controversial there
just pointing out a fact
that barack obama was
is
biracial he was raised by his white
mother and grandparents
but didn't identify with that side of
him at all identified as black that's
true
uh but that's why that's why she was
pulled off the air now espn
has
explaining its move it says at espn
we embrace different points of view
they just pulled off one of their one of
their star one of their main anchors for
expressing her point of view they pulled
her off air for that but they're only
doing it because they embraced this is
their this is their way of embracing
uh different points of view we embrace
different points of view dialogue and
discussion make this place great that
said we expect that those points of view
be expressed respectfully in a manner
consistent with our values and in line
with our internal policies we're having
direct conversations with sage and those
conversations will remain private
so you can have different points of view
as long as those points of view are in
keeping with
our values with the left's values
which which is another way of saying
that you can't have different points of
view at all
so this is this is
really important to understand she's
pulled off the air and this isn't even
there's no indication that she's a
republican or a conservative god forbid
uh there's not even any indication of
that i have no idea what her politics
are
i i would assume i don't know this i
would assume that she at least leans
heavily liberal only because i don't
know how you would survive for this long
at espn if you didn't
um but nothing that she said but taking
the obama stuff out of because that's
that's nothing at all there
with the vaccine
there's there's no reason why that has
to be a conservative right-wing talking
point
though as a conservative right-winger
i'm happy to take it
i mean if you want to insist
that um
you know standing up in favor of choice
when it comes to the drugs you put in
your body that that's now a conservative
point of view
fine i mean i'll i'll take that
but even as a conservative i don't see
any reason why it needs to be
that's what we hear from the left anyway
next we have protesters showed up at the
house of a school board member in
sarasota this is school board chairwoman
shirley brown
and uh
protesters upset about what's happening
in their school system upset about
critical race there and other things
they showed a better house
and this was this footage was making the
rounds on on the internet yesterday
people were condemning it
people on the left and the right saying
this is
beyond the pale we can't do this kind of
crosses a line
let's first check out some of the
footage here of these um
of these dastardly dangerous protesters
let's watch this
we see you in there shirley we want you
to come out for a redress of grievances
we know the next step is from mass to
vaccine and this will not happen
this is the lion we will die on
that's right no vaccines no to masks
shirley come on out shirley
we have some questions and we have some
demands that need to be mapped
so we've got uh we've got
it looks like maybe three guys there a
couple women and then some kids so a
handful of people it's like mostly kids
that are there
and they're holding some signs and
they've got an american flag and they've
got the bull horn
now here's what i'll say about this
uh this is obviously not how i choose to
protest
we we held a rally
as you know
in loudoun county we did it in front of
the school board meaning
we weren't going to their homes
that's not how i choose to protest it's
not how i recommend protesting
but
if you don't like this strategy
and especially if you're on the left and
you don't you don't like this
you don't like the idea of of
for example angry parents showing up at
the the homes of school board members
you only have yourself to blame
this is entirely your fault yes i'm
doing it you started it thing that's
exactly what i'm doing
and that is a legitimate point to make
here
just like you know we pretend that what
about ism you're never allowed to say
you're never allowed to frame an
argument with what about well what about
this
of course you can
if someone is criticizing something that
they themselves do
then it is perfectly valid for me to say
what about the fact that you do it
just like if they're criticizing
something
a method a strategy
that they themselves have been employing
and supporting and defending for years
is perfectly valid for me to say you
started this
this is on you
because what what we're finding out for
for a long time i mean the left has been
doing this exact thing
for years and years
and it's not they
don't don't say they're they only oh
they only choose the most powerful
people to do that's not true
i mean they go after politicians at
their homes they go after
uh
media personalities at their homes
they go into neighborhoods where there
isn't even anyone in particular there
who they have have a grievance against
except they just hate everybody in the
neighborhood because they assume they're
all you know white middle-class people
go into a white middle-upper-class
neighborhood with bullhorns in the
middle of the night
and harass everybody for no particular
reason
they'll do that to diners at a
restaurant we've seen so many videos
like that blm antifa showing up
harassing diners just sitting at a
restaurant
even when again there's no one there in
particular they have a special grievance
against
certainly nobody in any position of
power
so they've been pulling this move for
years and years
and the assumption has been and they've
gotten used to this they've gotten
comfortable with it
because the assumption has been that hey
we're we can do this kind of stuff we're
allowed to do this
you can't
and for a long time um for the most part
the right has kind of tacitly accepted
that
and said okay all right fine
we'll leave all that to you you guys can
do that but we we would never cross that
line
well those days are over now
there's a lot of people on the right
saying you know what if you're going to
do this we're going to do it too
we're not going to respect some code of
decorum
that you aren't respecting
we're we're not gonna to artificially
limit ourselves stand behind this
imaginary line
while you run around and do whatever you
want
okay we're not going to play a game with
you
where you've rigged the rules ahead of
time to give yourself every advantage
and we're not going to respect those
rules
we're not going to do that
that's what a lot of people on the right
are saying and um again if you don't
like it
and you're on the left it is your fault
100
100 your fault
you brought it on yourself
you know when when the left started
doing this kind of thing
uh i mean they've always been doing it
but when it became you know more a much
more prominent strategy
how many people on the left in media
how many how many of them came out and
said no no this is this is over the line
we can't do this
almost none
even when they're burning down buildings
and looting
and looting you know still
almost no one condemning it
and even the people who do condemn it
they always condemn it they always they
always couch their criticisms they're
very gentle criticisms by saying well i
understand why these people i understand
what they're upset about they feel
powerless they don't know what else to
do blah blah blah
so this is all on you all right
from uh axios it says a trillion dollar
platinum coin could be minted within
hours of the treasury secretary's
decision to do some do so according to
the former director of the united states
mint
congressional solutions to the debt
ceiling problem could take weeks to
implement especially if the
reconciliation reconciliation process is
used and time is running out in case of
emergency
a trillion dollar coin could be deployed
to bridge any gap between the money
running out and the debt ceiling being
used
um
so that's the idea now we we hear about
this
mint the coin and if you're on twitter
you might or social media might see the
hashtag
mint the coin
uh and that's that's what they're
talking about
to solve the uh the
the debt problem just
print a coin that says a trillion
dollars oh look at that we got a
trillion dollars now
now i'm
as you know i'm no economic
expert whatsoever i'm no economist
myself
intuitively this just seems
totally absurd
and also like
i doubt it will actually happen but if
it does that there would be significant
consequences to it and ramifications
i think i think in a way kind of
philosophically
the most serious ramification to
something like this the treasury just
minting a trillion dollar coin
you know
take a coin and say this is our magic
coin it's worth a trillion and if you're
gonna do that why only a trillion why
not two trillion
why not 10 trillion i mean it's just
like no limit especially when we're
dealing with figures like a trillion
these
cosmic
astronomical cosmic-sized figures
there's no limit
why not print a gazillion dollar coin
but when you when you hear about plans
like this
i think one one of the biggest problems
is it's it kind of breaks it's this
break the fourth wall type of moment
because our entire economic system
is built on this fiat currency this
money that's sort of a it's a it's a
fiction it's a story that we tell
ourselves
it has no real concrete value
and we all kind of
agree that we're going to pretend that
this stuff has value when it really it
doesn't doesn't have any actual inherent
value
we've we've agreed to pretend
so the money in our form of currency it
is like i said it's a it's a story that
we've that we're all telling each other
and we've all agreed
to take take part in this uh this
pageant and when you do something like
this i think it kind of breaks the
fourth wall
and it reminds everyone that oh this is
all fictional
i can't i can't spell out exactly what
the consequences are for that but they
don't seem very good
same for this uh treasury secretary
janet yellen you know she's been pushing
this idea just like the the the obama
minister the biden administration
freudian slipped there one in the same
the administration has been pushing this
plan
to
uh have the irs monitor
almost everybody's bank accounts any
bank account with 600 in it or a bank
account that has had 600 worth of
transactions over the course of a year
which is most bank accounts so like
every bank account except for the bank
account that maybe your you know 17 year
old cato works at mcdonald's has
everybody else they want to monitor
everyone's bank accounts
which means that they they're putting us
all under a permanent audit
and here she is on cnbc janet yellen
treasury secretary
explaining why this is so necessary to
do
there's an enormous tax gap in the
united states estimated it seven
trillion dollars over the next 10 years
in terms of a shortfall of tax
collections to what we believe are owed
and that that's not coming from people
failing to report wage income or
dividend income where there's good
information it comes from
places where the information on income
is opaque and can be hidden
how old is this per uh what
what is she got to be in her in her late
70s early 80s
the the entire gov this is not really
the point but
every time i see one of these people on
tv our entire government is being run by
people who are 80 plus
it's it's insane what we're doing
but she says that uh it's it's
what's happening with the money it's
opaque it's
hard to track well yeah it's supposed to
be
that's called privacy that's called
economic freedom
what this this thing that they're
pushing is is not getting a lot of
attention even from the right but
they're talking about
permanently erasing economic freedom out
the window it's gone
this isn't this isn't this isn't simply
an attack on our financial freedom in
our privacy it is the end of it
again it is effectively a permanent
audit of by the irs of all of us
permanently all the time
where they have direct access to your
bank accounts
now it's true that even right now
without any kind of policy or law like
this in place the irs can gain access to
your bank accounts
um
but there's a process they have to
follow on an individual basis to do that
at least
here we're throwing that out
and and somehow this is a gotten very
little attention
i think part of that is because the
assaults on our on our basic fundamental
liberties from the bind administration
are coming from 50 different angles
and it's hard to focus on one thing at a
time
you know it's like playing one against
50 and dodgeball and you've got all
these balls flying at you at one you
know at the same time you try to dodge
away from one end of getting hit by
another uh so that's part of the reason
also because the tyrants like you listen
to janet yellen
they aren't like tyrants in movies
or in you know the super villains in
comic books
they kind of bore you to death
yeah i listened to janet yellen for 17
seconds i almost fell asleep
but that's that's how actual tyrants
operate
they're not going to get on tv
cackling maniacally well they will if
camilla harris will but most of them
won't
they were like rubbing their hands
together and talking about their evil
plot to take over the world that's not
really the way it works
these are just like boring dull people
who come up with these
horrific tyrannical ideas and they
propose them and they they
defend them
in this really s
sanitized way heavy in euphemisms
and it can kind of lull you to sleep and
that's part of the strategy here
all right um
dave chappelle has a new comedy special
out and i haven't seen it yet i guess it
just came out yesterday the day before
but i already know that i'm gonna like
it based on the fact that the media is
having a hissy fit about it they're
condemning it as bigoted uh incendiary
all these things reckless dangerous
they're they're saying all of the things
that you should certainly want these
kinds of people to say if you're a
standard comedian and you've just you
know released a stand-up special
uh so he he talks about uh
transgenderism which is a theme that
he's returned to
in in several of his most recent comedy
specials at one point he says that
gender is a fact and he makes a point
that um only women can have babies and
he's right about that now if i want to
split hairs here and it's not really
splitting hairs but it is important to
say uh there's no g what you mean is
biological sex is a fact gender is
actually a fiction
that uh that that
gender theory proponents and members of
the gender called have invented
um
but i get what he's saying and that's
the basic point that he's making also he
talks about the rapper de baby
who
got into a lot of trouble recently
when he
made some comments about gay people
some anti-gay comments uh during a
during a concert
and people got very upset about that
and you may remember i talked about this
on my
show how the baby uh was being
criticized for these comments he made
about gay people
meanwhile you listen to any of his songs
and he's openly promoting and
encouraging people to kill each other
deal drugs all that kind of stuff
abuse women
none of that gets him in trouble
but the gay comments do
dave chappelle makes kind of that point
only he he actually uh brings something
up about the baby that i didn't even
know let's let's listen to this a lot of
the lgbtq community doesn't know the
baby's history he's a wild guy
he once shot
and killed him
in walmart
oh this is true google it the baby shot
and killed in walmart north carolina
nothing bad happened to his career
do you see where i'm going with this
in our country you can shoot and kill
but you better not hurt a gay person's
feelings
[Music]
so he actually he actually killed a guy
i looked i did look that up i did google
it
per uh dave chappelle's instructions and
it's true he killed a guy in walmart
of all places and look if you cannot be
safe at a walmart then where can you be
safe
and you know he survived that fine
in terms of uh public relations
that was no pr crisis
but he talks about gay people and that's
a problem
now
chappelle has been accused just like
when he makes comments about gender and
and in all of his previous standard
specials the left's got upset about
they always accuse him and are accusing
him again of uh of punching down
right he's this he's this wealthy
privileged guy
talking about the lgbt community this is
this is him punching down and comedians
should never punch down
well the first answer to that is that um
actually comedians should be their first
goal is to be funny
and so they should just be punching
wherever is the funniest to punch
okay
so it's punching up punching down as
long as it's funny you've done your job
as a comedian
but also
this is punching up this is speaking
truth to power
going after the lgbt community that is
punching up
because when a time when it comes to
cultural power
they have
all of it
so they they are the the unquestioned
untouchable authorities in in our
culture
the lgbt community is the is the the
sacred cow
that you can't criticize you can't say
anything about you can't make jokes
about them
you make jokes about anybody else almost
and uh that also depends on where you
fall on the internet intersectional
scale dave chappelle as a black man
according to the rules of the left he
can make jokes about almost anyone else
but not lgbt because they're higher up
on the victim ladder than he is
and since victimhood is power you know
faux victimhood
is power performative victimhood is
power
um
that makes the lgbt
lobby the most powerful in the country
so that is that is speaking truth to
power that is that is an example of
punching up
not that again it really matters
when it comes to a comedian
as long as they're being funny and
that's a funny joke
that's not really a joke and i did say
that first so i'm not gonna accuse dave
chappelle of
listening to my podcast and taking my
material but hey you draw your own
conclusions
all right finally this is uh
representative chris rabb who is a
legislator
from pennsylvania and he tweeted this
out a couple days ago he said i'll be
introducing a bill inspired by
representative kelly cassidy that
require requires all inseminators to
undergo vasectomies within six weeks of
having their third child or 40th
birthday
whichever comes first
additionally
my forthcoming bill will codify the
definition of wrongful conception to
include when a person has demonstrated
negligence toward preventing conception
during intercourse
this legislation will allow
pennsylvanians to take civil action
against inseminators for unwanted
pregnancies who wrongfully conceive a
child with them last this bill will
empower pennsylvanians to enforce this
prospective law by offering a 10 000
reward for reporting the proper
authorities those scoff laws who have
not complied with this statute within
the allotted time frame okay
so the main headline if there is one
here is that he wants uh he's going to
introduce a bill that would
require all men inseminators as he calls
them
to get a vasectomy after they have three
kids
or after they reach their 40th birthday
it's too late to have kids
now this is obviously a publicity stunt
clearly
and he's trying to make some kind of
point
about um
about pro-life laws that's that's the
idea
but what point is he actually making
the point is that he's a miserable
scumbag i guess that's the point i mean
and if that's what the point he's trying
to make then he certainly has made it
in order to what own the right he's
endorsed
you know the chinese communist policies
the instead of the one child policy
we're doing a three-child policy
that's how he's owning us
and the interesting thing is that what
you have here
with this bill
he's actually undermined his own case
because this is a great example
of what an attack on reproductive rights
would actually look like
not that as it stands right now this is
any chance of becoming a law in
pennsylvania but this is what an attack
on reproductive rights actually looks
like
where you are telling you in this case
you would be telling men
that they're not allowed to reproduce
anymore beyond a certain you're setting
a threshold and saying they can't
reproduce beyond that threshold
that's what an attack on reproductive
rights looks like
when you are trying to
prevent or control
reproduction itself
compare that to pro-life laws
and you see something entirely different
where women are certainly not being
prevented from reproducing
they're not being forced to reproduce
there are no controls being put on
reproduction whatsoever
all of the laws are governing what
happens
to the offspring
that have already been reproduced
a point that i've
made many times will continue to make
but here we find a
an interesting contrast that this guy
has provided to us
in an effort to make a in an effort to
criticize pro-life policies he's
actually demonstrated why his criticisms
of those policies are not valid
great good job let's get now to reading
the comments
who's rocking polka dots without
shame do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
uh g mack says why can't politicians
speak what the blunt truth matt walsh
uses i think lots of people long to hear
it
the main reason why
politicians don't speak blunt truth as
you point out it's
i think most people would say oh because
they're cowards
and certainly a lot of politicians are
but even more than that the bigger
problem is that
they just don't they don't care
they don't really believe
anything they don't believe the things
they pretend to believe this is the
problem with most republicans
even i kind of make the mistake of
talking about republicans as if their
main problem is that they're a bunch of
cowards and many of them are again
but before we even get to the cowardice
the issue before that one is that many
most of them don't really care about any
of these issues
uh garrett says i will ask your
weirdness one question i want to watch
the many saints of newark but i haven't
seen the sopranos
which should i watch first keep in mind
uh i may disregard your answer just do
what i want please do not smite me well
you're obviously banned from the show
for that i haven't seen the many states
of newark i've only watched one and a
half seasons of the sopranos
and uh i got to be honest with you
i i went i went into it
excited to watch the sopranos i i
watched it for the first time like two
years ago i completely missed it when it
first aired on hbo
and um
never felt back it felt like going back
and watching it
i'm not one of these people who can sit
down and watch
five episodes of a series in one night
so it takes me a long time to get
through an entire especially sopranos
has five or six seasons that's just a
long-term commitment and i've been
hesitant to do it but i finally said all
right everyone talks about the sopranos
like it's maybe the greatest show of all
time and i sat down to watch i really
wanted to like it
and i found it to be terribly overrated
i got to be honest with you
um
devin daniels says why did the trans
person keep insisting that their gender
be assumed by how they look
wouldn't that be gender stereotyping
yes with the sonic situation yeah they
they did uh he did
why
because
proponents of gender theory on the left
uh
gender theory itself is is completely
incoherent that's why
they can't help but contradict
themselves
with each new sentence they utter
because it's totally the entire concept
the entire theory is incoherent by its
nature
uh sam west says has anyone started a
gofundme for the sonic manager i want to
contribute i don't think anybody has yet
if if the if that manager is fired by
sonic and i've been checking to see if
they actually did fire this guy
so far i haven't seen anything about it
so as far as i know they haven't
but if they do then i'll start to go
fund me myself and something else is
this would be a time for a real boycott
an actual organized boycott of sonic if
they do fire this man
is the victim of
public shaming and bullying
by this uh man who identifies as a woman
uh let's see major tom fisher says matt
do you think that facebook twitter etc
will eventually compete with corporate
media for narrative power or do you
think that the objective of corporate
media is merely to just enforce the same
rules on social media it seems like both
factions lean hard left but both want to
consolidate and exercise massive
propaganda power
um
yeah the narrative of facebook and
twitter is the same as corporate media
that's the point
they have the same narrative goals
but many of the people who use these
social media platforms don't
and as far as that goes i think um
i i think that the
you know conservatives on social media
are already very much competing with
corporate media for narrative
power uh i i don't know that we could
say that we've overtaken i mean the
corporate media still exercises a lot of
control and power over the over the
narrative
but there is a stiff competition right
now that's for sure
and that's exactly why they're pushing
this right now
because they see where the trends are
heading
uh karen says i got my sbg t-shirt last
week and when my husband saw it he asked
what that's what that what's that all
about i told him matt walsh fans are
called the sweet baby gang he said who's
matt walsh
when my son saw me later he asked why do
you have a guy in a diaper on your shirt
when my 11 year old daughter saw it she
said oh cool you got a matte wall shirt
now i know
who knows me best look i would never
advocate karen for something like this
i would never advocate for this under
normal circumstances
and i'm very hesitant to say this and i
say this solemnly um
but
i think you need to consider disowning
your son and divorcing your husband
drastic move i understand
i'm just kidding but not really now a
word from paint your life you know
paintyourlife.com i've been telling you
about painting your life for for a while
now we've got some paint your life
paintings in our own house and the other
great thing about them is that they make
they make a great gift in fact this was
my gift to to my mom whose birthday was
uh it was recent
recently came up and it was a it was a
big hit the great thing is it's a great
gift
that actually and it's thoughtful but it
requires very little effort on your part
because all you're doing is you're
sending paint your life
any kind of picture any valuable
cherished memory that you have and
they're going to convert that into a
beautiful work of art using their with
their world-class artists and you can
also work with them to make sure that
each detail is perfect so again you just
send any picture of yourself your
children
um
family special place special memory and
they're going to convert that into a
great painting it makes perfect birthday
anniversary wedding gift anything
it's meaningful it's personal and these
are memories that can be cherished
forever at paintyourlife.com there's no
risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer get twenty percent off your
painting that's right twenty percent off
and free shipping so to get a special
offer text the word match this to sixty
four thousand that's matt to sixty four
thousand text matt to sixty four
thousand paint your life celebrate the
mat the moments that matter most terms
apply available at paint your life dot
com slash terms again text matt to 64
000. and you know in a world full of
hyperbole and propaganda you deserve
these straight up facts that's why we
started our new podcast morning wire
which has been topping the app on
spotify charts since its recent release
it's the only daily news podcast that
values your time and the truth and while
we're working overtime to bring you the
news you need to know we need your help
to keep the facts trending towards
number one so subscribe and start
listening to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and leave a five star review if
you like what you hear let's get now to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
now we cancel once again noted race
hustler ibram henry rogers better known
by his stage name iberomex candy but
this is not just about him today we're
cancelling a large and ever-growing
group of people of which kennedy is
among the most prominent representatives
the daily wire reports uh quote jesus
was a radical revolutionary that
dedicated to the destruction of the
american empire and every church should
be a home of revolutionaries hebermex
candy the best-selling author of how to
be an anti-racist said in a recent
interview kennedy said that he believes
in black liberation theology as opposed
to white evangelical theology which
allegedly teaches that black people are
quote a backward uncivilized sort of
savage race and jesus came to save black
people and so-called white trash from
themselves
kennedy expounded on his religious views
during an hour-long interview pro
program sponsored by uproxx titled
people's party with talib quali quali
began the religious discussion quote any
gospel that does not speak to liberation
is not truly gospel the understanding of
jesus is a as a radical revolutionary
nowadays is more popular than it used to
be something he credits to cornell west
the honorary chairman of the democrat
socialist of america and faculty member
at union theological seminary
now kenny has been preaching this line
for a long time of course and he's gone
into greater detail in the past here he
is at a church
in manhattan explaining this concept of
liberation theology listen
liberation theology in other words jesus
was a revolutionary
and the job of the christian
is to revolutionize society
that the job of the christian is to
liberate society
from the powers on on earth that are
oppressing humanity
everybody understand that so
that's liberation theology in a nutshell
savior theology
is a different type of theology the job
of the christian
is to go out
and save
these individuals who are behaviorally
deficient
in other words we're to bring them into
the church
these individuals
who
are doing all of these evil sinful
things and heal them
and save them
and then once we've saved them
we've done our jobs
and and to me anti-racists
fundamentally reject
savior theology that goes right in line
with racist ideas in racist theology in
which they say you know what
black people
other racial groups the reason why
they're struggling on earth is because
of what they're behaviorally doing wrong
and it is my job as the pastor to sort
of save these wayward black people or
wayward poor people or wayward queer
people
that type of theology
breeds bigotry
well yeah the cause of many of our
struggles for people from all groups and
walks of life is what we are
behaviorally doing wrong this is
otherwise known as sin we are sinners in
a sinful world and our sin the evil that
we choose to do
is what causes much of the pain and
misery we all experience this is a basic
christian concept and like so many
christian concepts it's also common
sense
it should be obvious to anyone christian
or not that the world is in the shape
it's in largely because of choices that
people make
kenny of course because it's his whole
shtick racializes the issue he claims
that those dastardly proponents of
savior theology otherwise known as
christian theology or biblical theology
are really focused on as he puts it
saving wayward black people
as always
the victim complex is driven by
narcissism candy imagines
that he as a black person is everybody's
primary focus he imagines that white
people in church on sunday are sitting
there thinking man what can we do about
these black people
now it's true that a great many of the
problems in the black community are
caused by choices that people in that
community make just as again the
majority of problems in any community
are caused by the choices people within
that community make but it may shock
candy to be informed that white people
sitting in church or kneeling in prayer
are like anyone else primarily focused
on their own lives and on their families
they aren't thinking what can i do about
this other racial group they're thinking
about you know what can i do about my
family's struggles about my struggles
about my kids
and the savior of theology as kenny
labels it thinking the term is somehow
pejorative
provides the answer you bring it all
before christ he saves he he heals
the proponents of this theology uh don't
think that they themselves can save and
heal but that jesus can
and if you don't think that
then you're not christian
candy is not christian liberation
theology is not a christian theology
it is its own religion
the reason it's not christian well one
of the many reasons we can't we don't
have time to go through an exhaustive
list
is that it's entirely earthbound
it is predicated on a belief
in a likewise earthbound jesus
candy and those in his camp say that
jesus was some sort of political
revolutionary dedicated to reshaping
human society and solving our political
and social problems it's not a
coincidence that this version of jesus
the political revolutionary version
is one that many atheists favor as well
they also seek an earthbound jesus but
the problem for the atheists and for
kendy's camp and i say that as if
they're two different groups and they're
really not
is that the gospels don't make that
jesus available to us
of course in order to know what the
gospel says about jesus you have to read
the gospels first a step that kenny
doesn't seem to have taken but when you
do
you'll perhaps be surprised to discover
that jesus was no political activist
he wasn't organizing marches and rallies
he wasn't out campaigning for causes
he did criticize the corrupt authorities
of his day because his work his actual
work naturally put him in conflict with
those authorities
but most of his ethical and moral
preaching focused on universal and
timeless moral truths
the sermon on the mount for example was
chock full of timeless moral truths
he didn't spend a lot of time on
specific political and social issues
even when his enemies tried to force him
into it by backing him into a corner you
know when he was of course asked about
the taxes
he simply said give to caesar what a
caesars
he didn't spell out exactly what tax
rate we should all be paying
he could have but he didn't he didn't
take a position on the debate between a
progressive tax or a flat tax
he never said anything about which
economic system he favors
all this ridiculous debate was jesus a
socialist
he didn't he'd no he wasn't he didn't
endorse socialism he also didn't offer
any defenses of liber of a libertarian
free-market principles
that simply was not the point
of christ's ministry
the primary point of his ministry was
the saving work of salvation that he had
come to perform yes he wanted to
liberate mankind but liberate us from
sin from eternal death not not from
merely earthly oppression and suffering
if you remove or ignore the eternal
element
of christ's mission and of christianity
itself
then you've removed or ignored the
fundamental point of it all what candy
wants to do again no different from any
other secularist
is strip away all that is supernatural
and eternal from the gospels and leave
only the earthly finite leftovers but
that's that there's not much left when
you do that that's the problem
if you take jesus's miracles off the
table
and all of us talk about his salvific
mission
his actual resurrection
um
what are you left with
some valuable moral lessons certainly
but uh that's it
i mean you're left with a guy who walked
around 2000 years ago said some nice
things
and then died and rotted away and became
dust
you're not even left with a political
revolutionary or any sort of
historically significant ethical teacher
there's not enough meat left on the
bones to support that version of jesus
once you've taken all of the
supernatural things away
so the choice
now we hear c.s lewis had the the
trilemma
um jesus was either a lord liar lunatic
i think it's more simple than that
there's actually two there's only two
choices were given by the gospels when
it comes to jesus either
he was the most significant person to
ever live and he still lives because he
was
greater than a person much more than a
person
or
he was someone of almost no significance
who was mythologized later on
those are really your two options
lots of people can be included look for
some third option that just isn't there
but a real christian has no problem
choosing the first option
kenny doesn't like that option because
he's not a christian
and that's why he's canceled today
not canceled because he's not a
christian
but because he he's not one while
pretending to be
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike cormina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright
dailywire 2021.
an australian state has citizens sending
selfies to the government to prove they
haven't left their homes the cdc floats
another virtual thanksgiving quote
unquote and most millionaires don't want
to leave money to their lazy kids i
don't blame them check it out on the
michael knowles show